it has now been just about three weeks
since the news media began breathlessly
fear-mongering about the new
omicron variant
it was spreading like wildfire we were
told we needed to mask up again we were
told we might need to lock down so now
the data are in
so far
according to the cdc
there have been
43 cases of omicron detected in the
united states
not 43 000 not 4300
not 430. 43.
of those 43 people who came down with
the kron
34 of them almost 80 percent
had taken the full regimen of fouchy
ouchies they were
fully vaccinated and they got it anyway
of those 34
14 of them 41
had received a booster shot
they were more than fully vaccinated
they had taken
extra fouchy ouchies of the whole crew
just one person was hospitalized and
that was for a very short period of time
not a single person
has died
this is
wonderful news
to everyone except for the sociopaths
who want to keep us all locked down i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from dominic
zelenak who says
hillary clinton should help jesse with
his post-trial victory speech that's a
good idea and then in about four or five
years while jesse is sitting in an
orange jumpsuit he can tearfully read
his his acquittal speech it's his
exoneration speech that would be
wonderful he you know
he
if he really wanted to look better if he
really wanted to beautify himself for
that moment which unfortunately for him
will never come
he might consider wearing pearl jewelry
we all could consider a little pearl
jewelry especially this christmas time
so when you do i recommend checking out
raw source gentlemen i know that you
think that you've got all the time in
the world to get your lucky lady
something for christmas i know i've been
there i've done this well time is
running out
i've got a great opportunity for you
right you got to make a move now the
pearl source at the pearl source you get
the highest quality pearl jewelry at up
to 70 off retail prices why because the
pearl source cuts out the middlemen by
eliminating those crazy jewelry store
markups and selling directly to you the
consumer
at the pearl source you will find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere each jewelry piece is custom
made specifically for you pearls are a
classic timeless wonderful gift for
christmas order now there are global
supply chain problems
shipping characters carriers rather are
expecting major delays of delivery times
this is your last chance go head on over
the pearl source offers fast free
two-day shipping zero contact delivery
she's going to love it a no-hassle
60-day money-back guarantee free return
shipping for a limited time listeners to
this show can get 20 off your entire
order do not wait until it's too late to
do your christmas shopping go to
theprosource.com
knowles enter promo code knowles at
checkout for 20 off your entire order if
you want fine pearl jewelry at the best
prices online go straight to the source
the
slash knowles promo code knowles at
checkout the omicron
is not apparently as scary as we were
told that it's going to be isn't that
good in a normal country in normal times
that would be considered a good thing oh
it's more mild
oh it's not killing or hospitalizing or
oh that
that many people that's great
wonderful no not wonderful
according to the public health officials
and the fear mongers because
the the real threat posed by omicron for
them is that they won't be able to hold
on to their power so they're gripping on
as tightly as they possibly can
right now in portland oregon
children are being forced to eat lunch
outside i don't know if you're very
familiar with portland oregon but it's a
little chilly there some day can be it
can get a little cold
kindergarteners this story came out last
week kindergarteners were forced to eat
lunch outside separated on these little
buckets so that they can social distance
in 40 degree weather maybe a little bit
colder
at the capitol hill elementary school
there
and that way they won't be near their
friends they can't huddle for warmth and
they're going to sit outside so they're
not going to catch the woofloo they
might catch pneumonia which is going to
be a lot more dangerous for the kids but
at least they'll be able to avoid the
omicron which has not
seriously affected anybody in the united
states does that make sense to you no it
doesn't make much sense to me either
seems
ignorant
seems like child abuse
but it seems like it's not letting up
anytime soon dr fauci the most powerful
politician in the country
was just asked on abc news
when he thought the two weeks to slow
the spread were going to come to an end
when he thought okay people are fully
vaccinated when can we go back to normal
and he said well
not
not everyone has had their booster shot
yet i think if you look at the data the
more and more it becomes clear that if
you want to be optimally protected you
really should get a booster and i think
we'll be continuing to evaluate what the
official designation is but for now if
you want to be optimally protected
absolutely get a booster if you've
already had your primary vaccination
and projecting forward should we be
expecting yearly boosters if it becomes
necessary to get yet another boost then
we'll just have to deal with it when
that curves but i'm hoping from an
immunological standpoint that that third
shot of an mrna and the second shot of a
j and j will give a much greater
durability of protection than just the
six months or so that we're seeing right
now
well we're just gonna have to wait and
see george
i guess you're gonna have to have me
back on your television program next
year and ask me for
permission
to go back to your life or ask me if you
need another another shot in the arm and
then i'll decide then because i am the
great and exalted dr fauci all will bow
down before me
george
thank you back to you george
we're already on the fourth shot now
we're not on the fourth shot right now
but there are countries around the world
that are israel
is openly contemplating among the
israeli health agencies
requiring a fourth shot of the mrna to
be considered fully vaccinated that's
already happening
and this guy's playing dumb
he's playing dumb and he's playing koi
he's like i don't know
we'll see just the most important thing
is to ask me and then i'll give you
permission or i won't
or i won't
obviously the man has no credibility the
public health apparatus has no
credibility anymore because they have
not only gotten things wrong but they've
also lied to us and that guy's a lied to
us and he's lied to us from the very
beginning he lied to us on the masks and
he admitted that he lied to us on the
masks he misrepresented not only the
science or something he misrepresented
his own views about the science and he
said he told people not to wear the
masks because he wanted to save them for
his friends in public health
so no credibility whatsoever
and and
he doesn't even need the credibility
because he's not giving us a timetable
it used to be no two more weeks no one
more month no three more months no just
this shot and then you're but now he's
saying i hope yeah i hope hope the extra
shot is enough but you know we'll see
ask me then
they keep
changing all the rules that is a feature
not a bug of the covid regime
of the public health
dictatorship that we're now living under
because if there were clear rules that
were set
then they would have wouldn't have the
power that they do but if the rules are
contingent upon their own whims and
caprices then they do have all of the
power elizabeth warren
seems to be projecting a little bit when
she's looking at this asymmetry of power
between the left and the right elizabeth
warren just went on don lemon's show
he's still on cnn for now
he hasn't he hasn't been booted yet like
his buddy fredo so
elizabeth warren
was discussing
a federal election takeover that the
democrats are trying to push and she
said that the the left has to do this
because right now a small group of
extremists are
attempting to change the laws
to hold on to their minority power
i would have gotten rid of the
filibuster overall years ago
but right now it's what's holding us up
on the voting rights bill
uh and we've got
almost everybody on board to be able to
either change the filibuster overall or
create an exception
but look this is the most important
thing we've got to do we have got to get
voting rights passed through
we are now dealing with a major
political party that has decided that
the only way they can win
is by changing the laws to keep an
extremist
minority
in power regardless of what voters want
and so we just got to pass this voting
rights bill and uh we're all working on
it that was senator pot ladies and
gentlemen that was senator pott
calling the kettle
black
senator i'm
calling the kettle a person of color i'm
sorry i don't want to be offensive
elizabeth warren
saying that we need to
change the laws
to stop a
uh group of politicians from changing
the laws to protect their power and and
the reason that we got to change the
laws and the procedures in the senate is
to pass a federal election takeover that
will that will fundamentally change our
constitutional order and give democrats
a permanent electoral advantage and we
have to do that so that the republicans
don't do that or something
seems like projection to me
especially when you consider elizabeth
warren's approval rating
elizabeth warren's approval rating in
the doldrums
as is pete booted judges as is kamala
harris's as is the approval rating of
the congressional democrats and the
senate democrats and the president of
the united states joe biden
they have very little support right now
for a number of reasons they're failing
on every single issue i i'm saying
they're obviously literally they're
failing in in terms of doing their job
but the american people view them as
failing as well including on covet that
was the one issue that biden was still
above water on at least for some period
of time he no longer is obviously on the
economy he's completely in the doldrums
and so
you've got
a group of people with minority support
a very small amount of public support
trying to change the rules and hold on
to their power and make that power
permanent but not only do the democrats
not have majority support among the
american people according to public
opinion polls they don't even have
majority support among democrats there's
a new poll out
looking at 2024 that shows that only 37
of democrats want joe biden to be their
nominee
in
2024 well they're going to have to do
something to protect
their electoral viability and when you
want to protect yourself in your home i
would strongly recommend you check out
ring this christmas season you're going
to want to protect your own home because
people show up maybe they're delivering
presents maybe they're delivering
in-laws and maybe you're going to want
to open the door sometimes and maybe
you're going to want to not open the
door sometimes
you're also going to want to give out
the gift of protection a gift that makes
you feel like you're living in the
jetsons really high quality technology
at a really low price that is going to
keep your friends
safe and sound which is why you got to
check out
ring alarm you know about the ring video
doorbell you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door whether you're
in the house or outside the house or
wherever
ring also has a powerful alarm system
it's amazing it lets you protect every
inch of your house not just for security
purposes but from freeze from fire from
flooding it costs very very little you
get a whole year of ring alarm for what
you'd pay for one month of those
old-timey
security systems this christmas season
deck the halls walls doors and windows
with the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles scanner wles get a great deal on
a ring alarm security kit today that is
ring.com
knowles according to a new poll in i
slash tipp poll
on uh on monday last monday over one
third of
just a little over one third of
democrats want biden as the candidate on
the 2024 presidential ticket another 16
percent of democrats chose kamala harris
16 not great
and 13 remain overall
unsure
this is really really rough for them it
would be one thing
if 37 of democrats wanted joe biden and
45 percent of democrats wanted kamala
harris or 50 obviously 50 or greater one
of kamala harris that would be much
easier joe biden could retire go quietly
off into the sunset he probably wouldn't
even know that it was happening and then
kamala harris could take over she would
appear to be the heir apparent but
the problem for the heir apparent is
that she's significantly less popular
than joe biden joe biden's approval
rating is somewhere around 38
kamala harris is somewhere around 27 28
so it's it's
much much worse
so they don't have it so what are they
going to have to do
they're going to have to
maintain a sense of crisis and emergency
both to scare people into not changing
horses in the middle of our great fight
against covid and omicron goodness
gracious a 44th person might come down
with omicron if we don't keep joe biden
in power but
they'll also need to do that in order to
justify their cheating in all of the
elections um this is not a conspiracy
theory you heard elizabeth warren
talking about it she wants to pass
federal legislation to give congress
and the
federal government now run by democrats
the opportunity to control all of these
local elections this would be a
reordering of our constitutional system
they want to do that
to make permanent all of the shenanigans
that you saw in 2020 where they
reordered how the elections took place
where they got rid of election day and
turned it into election month where they
they just openly ignored
prohibitions state by state against
widespread mail-in ballots that's what
you saw in pennsylvania they just
ignored it they just broke the law
where they did not count the ballots on
election night but it went on for days
and days and weeks until finally the
numbers seem to work for them they want
to make these kinds of things permanent
it's the only way they're getting
re-elected
there's it's
virtually impossible to come back from
numbers
like this
and what are you going to do about it
what are you going to do well one hopes
that 2022 is a good year for republicans
and we can gain a little political power
and we won't be squishes and they'll
they'll actually have the courage to
wield that political power looking into
2024 but as of now the public health
bureaucracy which is the necessary tool
to maintain this sense of crisis and
emergency and change all the election
rules they are going full steam ahead
and you might need you shut and you
might need your ready shot you might
need 50 more shots before 20
24. speaking of changing all the rules
in a way that is absurd and obviously
unjust
this dude who's swimming on the u-pen
women's swimming team
continues to smash all of the records
and brag about it as well
this would be will thomas he now goes by
the name leah and he's just a hulking
dude who keeps smashing women's records
and all the girls on the team have to
pretend to be happy about it even though
a lot of them are now speaking with
media outlets saying this is clearly
unfair and he's taking all of our
trophies and he's taking all of our
accolades and scholarships and and all
the rest of it
so one teammate told outkick
that this fella will thomas bragged
after winning the 200 freestyle at the
akron zippy invitational he said quote
that was so easy i was cruising
and after winning the 300 freestyle
he was he was happy that he won but he
was disappointed with his time and he
said at least i'm still number one in
the country
in front of his teammates
ah darn i i beat all you girls obviously
because i'm a dude but
ah gosh i should have done a little
better oh well at least i'm number one
yeah you're
number one in a category that you don't
belong to so how do we fix this
conservatives feel and even some
moderate liberals feel perfectly
comfortable saying that this is wrong
this is why so much of the cultural
battle over weird sex issues is focused
on women's sports right now women's
sports something about which virtually
no one actually cares but we all have to
pretend that we
the most important justice issue in
america is the upenn women's swimming
team
but it's not that's a symbol of a much
deeper issue and we're not going to fix
this issue unless we fix fundamental
issues
and a lot of people are not going to
want to do that a lot of moderate
liberals are not going to want to do
that certainly and even a lot of
conservatives are not going to want to
do that
because the fundamental issue
is that men are not women as we've said
before right that's fundamentally what's
wrong it's not just that men have more
bone density and they've got bigger
muscles and so they can do swim faster
and no
the fundamental issue is that they're
different but if men and women are
different then the transgender bathrooms
100 have to go because men shouldn't go
into the women's bathroom
and if men and women really are
different
and for instance doctors
take an oath to do no harm and to help
care for the health of patients then the
transgender surgery it's got to go not
just for kids we all agree on that but
for adults too it's not helping them
they're not really women
that's not medical care that's harming
them that's mutilating them
that's indulging a lie in a fantasy so
that surgery it's got to go it's got to
be banned you got it you actually you
have to get rid of it
let's go a little further than that
the bostock decision there was a supreme
court decision that neil gorsuch
squished on he said that there's a
constitutional civil rights law
protection
for
for sexual identity even if your sexual
identity is different than your actual
sex that's got to go let's go further
than that obergefell the decision that
invented this new definition of marriage
if men and women really are different
then the right that you have to get
married
does not imply a right for two men or
two women to have a union that they call
marriage because men and women are
different now are you comfortable with
that maybe you're not i think i might be
starting to lose some people now
i'm just telling you what we've got to
do to get rid of this insane upend
dude swimming on the women's team just
talking about the fundamental issues but
maybe we start to feel a little
uncomfortable
ah she gotta wow you have to overturn
gay marriage yeah of course you do if
men and women really are different then
of course you do
because then there's
the right for
marriage the right for a man and woman
to get married does not extend
to men to two men and to two women
let's go even further than that
lawrence v texas this was a law this was
a ruling rather
that found sodomy laws to be
unconstitutional there were a lot of
laws on the books that said that
you can't
have gay sexual behavior
it's not about your identity or your
desires but it's about your your
behavior
and
conservatives in that case dissented
they said there's no right to this kind
of sexual behavior
the laws are basically never enforced
and haven't certainly haven't been
enforced for a very very long time at
all
and the laws might be stupid they might
be in scalia's words stupid but
constitutional
but the point is there is no
constitutional right to that kind of
behavior
based on equal protection or any other
reason because
men and women are different are you
willing to overrule that decision now
we've lost a lot of people
now now
let's go back to the sexual revolution
in the 1960s
and not we're not just talking about the
transgender people and we're not just
talking about
the homosexuals we're talking about boys
and girls just generally
are you willing to undo the sexual
revolution that says that men and women
react to sex in exactly the same way
that men and women have the same
desires for sex that men and women face
the same consequences for sex this is
where the pro-abortion movement came
from is because women men and women are
different and so they've got different
consequences from sex and so in order to
pretend that men and women are exactly
the same women have to be able to kill
their kids
we've got to overrule roe i think a lot
of us could get on board with that
but we've also got to stop the fiction
that men and women are exactly the same
in every way and there's nothing
different about them are you willing to
go that far i don't know so the reason i
take you on this little trip down memory
lane and this little trip down
some
legal thinking and philosophical
thinking
and anthropological thinking
is because it's not so easy to kick the
dude off the women's swim team
the
errors that have led to the point where
a hulking dude beats all the women in
the
swimming races
and
we're all supposed to applaud it those
errors built up over many many decades
and they did so subtly and they did so
probably with the best of intentions and
everyone just trying to be nice and
trying to say no well maybe let's just
pretend this thing about women or this
thing about sex or this thing about
desire
and then the conclusion of that doesn't
seem very
compassionate at all certainly not to
the women on the team
and it doesn't seem
real it doesn't seem true
but does anyone including conservatives
have the guts to actually go back
and correct some of those errors i hope
so
but i'm i'm not betting on the spinal
fortitude of the gop
just trying to show you things clearly
when you want to see things clearly in a
way that won't strain your
your eyes or your head i would recommend
you check out blue blocks blue light can
damage our eyes and lead to digital eye
strain i am particularly prone to this i
don't know why but i get a lot of these
headaches and things for some people it
can heighten anxiety depression it can
deplete your energy
if you want to get rid of that blue
light that nasty blue light you got to
check out blue blocks i got pretty hip
to this years ago
i have not
looked at screens with some exception
that have the blue light coming through
in years i love blue blocks blue blocks
are made under laboratory
optics laboratory conditions in
australia unlike other blue light
classes out there they are
evidence-backed they're really really
high quality they've got over 40 hip and
cool frames they come in prescription
non-prescription and readers they've got
frames for every single need they're
also giving back by working in
partnership with restoring vision in
their buy one gift one campaign for each
pair of blue blocks glasses purchased
they donate a pair of reading glasses to
someone in need head on over to
blueblocks.com knowles use promo code
knowledge to check out get 20 off and
enjoy free shipping on orders over 115
bucks get your energy back sleep better
block out the unhealthy effects of blue
light with blue blocks b l u b l o x dot
com slash knowles or click the link
below make sure you use the code knowles
to get 20 off your order and enjoy free
shipping over 115 bucks
b-l-u-b-lox dot com slash knowles for 20
off today you know the daily wire is
leading the charge against the biden
administration's vaccine mandates not
only were we the first in the nation to
sue the biden administration for their
unconstitutional mandate but we're
getting closer to a million signatures
on our do not comply petition every
single day because people are realizing
that if we don't actively fight for our
freedom the government will take it the
supreme court turned away two emergency
requests from health care workers
doctors and nurses in new york to block
the state's vaccine mandate so we got
good news from the fifth circuit we got
good news from the sixth circuit but
you're still getting some bad news then
out of new york we've got a goal of
reaching 1 million signatures we've got
over 850 000 signatures so far
we need your help we need your help to
cross the finish line
so please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply then share
your petition with all of your friends
and family we'll be right back with a
lot more
speaking of men winning awards
time magazine has just named the man of
the year i think now we're supposed to
call it person of the year because we're
supposed to believe that men and women
are exactly the same and so time has
named the person of the year for 2021
and that person
is elon musk the ceo of tesla
and spacex
the richest person in the world at least
depending on the day you know these
things fluctuate a little bit but he has
been
the richest person in the world here is
the editor of time explaining their
choice the person of the year is elon
musk okay he is reshaping
life on earth and possibly life off
earth as well and and this is someone
also who
in becoming the richest person in the
history of the world this year really
speaks to the moment we're into this
very complex moment in the world some
people may look at elon musk and he's
got foes too i mean he's a rich guy
who's done a lot but there are a lot of
detroit fans and foes yeah legions of
them he's
you you look at tesla this year his
electric car company became the biggest
car company in the world by far
electric vehicles now really in the
mainstream and that's his doing
spacex his space company is the global
commercial leader in space nasa chose it
to get astronauts back on the moon for
the first time in 50 years and as i said
we are in this kind of new gilded age
where like it or not
so much of our lives even in this moment
of incredible inequality are being
shaped by these very wealthy tech
leaders
i'm
always in the business of attacking time
magazine and similar legacy institutions
in the media that are usually just
completely full of it and have a
terrible left-wing slant
i think this was a good choice
i think this is a great choice he is
sort of the man of the year
he has a great claim to it elon musk
he
is
a singular individual
and the thing i like most about him is
that he doesn't get mired in nonsense we
are constantly mired in nonsense if you
want to be involved in politics at all
and especially today you've got to be
mired in just a little bit of nonsense
and all the issues some of the issues
matter a great deal but some are just
kind of distractions and elon doesn't
really seem to do that
elon just does what he's going to do
he's going to reinvent the electric car
okay and that's fine and it doesn't
matter if a republican's president or a
democrat he's just going to do it and
then they're going to try to
tax him a lot and put a lot of burdens
on him okay he's just going to leave
he's going to go to another state but
he's going to keep making his electric
car and he you know he wants to go into
outer space he's going to do that too
and he's just going to do it and we can
all chit chat about whatever nonsense
but he's just going to go ahead and do
what he's what he wants to do
he's got his sights set
a little bit further and this is an
important thing to keep in mind
you know ultimately we need to keep our
sights set further than
the physical world we've got to keep our
sights set on things that are eternal at
least elon musk though is keeping his
sights set on things beyond the borders
of the united states beyond the
atmosphere he's keeping his sights set a
little bit further good lesson for all
of us i have nothing negative to say
about this
just the first it's the first news story
in a very long time i've had nothing
negative to say so to balance that out
to balance out the man of the year i've
got to
mention
whatever whatever the opposite of that
is whatever the
the
degendered person of the year the
gelded person of the year i'm talking
about
prince harry
poor prince
harry this is a headline just came out
about prince harry prince harry says
quitting can be good for your mental
health
uh prince harry was addressing
a fast company he had a q a with the
magazine fast company he's talking about
his his work as the chief
impact officer
of the mental health company better up
none of this none of this sounds real
none of this sounds like it actually
does anything or a chief impact officer
of this of a what is a mental health
company better up
and uh prince harry decided that
it is
sometimes really good for your mental
health to quit
why is this on harry's mind
because he quit his family
he decided to stop being a duke and a
prince so that he could become
some fake millennial position at some
dubious sounding startup
prince harry is the voice of our
generation
i'm sorry to say
he left something with honor and
nobility real nobility royalty
a job that was about duty
and not about the self
he left all of that behind
to
chase celebrity
and
fleeting kind of fashionableness
and
the
applause of
millennials
and to focus entirely on himself
the argument that the only
somewhat plausible argument he gave for
why he had to leave the royal family is
that he was getting too much attention
and too much publicity and that was
harming his family and what has he done
since he left the royal family he has
sought out attention and publicity as
much as he possibly can
but not in the dignified way that the
royals have to deal with publicity
even all the tabloids their job is to
remain dignified amid
all of the tabloid
gossiping and sometimes they're more
successful at that than others but but
harry is now he says i need my privacy
and he goes on every podcast in america
and then he goes and talks to every
magazine in america and he focuses on
his mental health and he focuses on how
important it is to quit it's not it's
you know what's better than quitting not
quitting buddy you know what's better
than just focusing on yourself all the
time
focusing on other people
a man wrapped up in himself makes a
small package indeed
and it's it's ironic he might be sincere
about this he might be sincerely wrong
but what
prince harry seems to believe
is that the more you focus on yourself
the happier you'll be and
anyone who has ever
pursued that path knows the opposite is
true the more you focus on yourself the
crazier you get the less happy you are
the more you focus on others and duty
and honor and virtues the happier
actually you will
be and you do this not by
shirking responsibility and only
indulging your own desires and whims and
pleasures it's the opposite you do it by
not quitting by working by working not
just for yourself but for others
speaking of bad family decisions
jesse smollette
has
the p the pr machine behind jesse
smollett has tried to defend their man
in any way that they can
jesse
made the hoax claim the hate crime claim
everyone jumped his defense the whole
thing completely fell apart now he's
been found guilty on five counts
he may see jail time
and so the pr machine is still working
overdrive they're saying it's his family
well he grew up in this family
environment and you know what frankly
his family may have had a great deal of
influence on how jesse jesse got to the
point that he is today this was a new
york times article from about five years
ago
so this is before the fake attack the
smilet family business acting and
activism
here's what jesse said
my mom was in the movement
the he's referring to the black panther
movement this radical
black nationalist militant movement
my mom was in the movement with bobby
seal and huey newton and one of her
first mentors was julian bond
mr smellet said of the black panther
founders and the civil rights leader to
this day angela davis is one of her
dearest friends we've spent mother's day
with angela angela davis is a communist
terrorist
so
i do feel a little bad for jesse because
when he was a kid his mother had him
hanging around with terrorists and
communists
and black nationalists
crucially whose views of the world
were very different from reality
his parents filled his head with the
lies of commies and terrorists i'm not
saying commies in the glib way that we
conservatives sometimes do where anyone
to the left of us we call it i mean
actual communists like angela davis
and growing up steeped in those lies
jesse probably believed them
and he probably believed that every time
black men walked out onto the street
they were being hunted down and chased
and he probably believed that he could
never achieve anything because he was a
black man an american perfectly
oppressed by the white evil white man
and he probably believed he probably
believed that the south side of chicago
was maga country where white men and
maga hats
very likely could walk up to him with a
noose and try to attack him so if he
were going to perpetrate a hoax to get
attention
actually it wouldn't be so divorced from
reality actually it might be in
furtherance of the truth because while
that specific instance was a lie it gets
to a greater truth as we are always told
by these liars and deceivers
i
i wouldn't be surprised at all the
marxists have this idea
of the false consciousness
and this idea of the false consciousness
was developed not just by the early
cultural marxists about whom i write in
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available for
christmas makes a fabulous present
but also really developed by the second
wave feminists who would have what i
call wine and cheese soirees w-h-i-n-e
and they would invite these happy
housewives to come over to their wine
and cheese parties at the new new york
radical women's groups and convince them
that they were all terribly oppressed
and they were all really unhappy so the
women would go in happy and they'd walk
out miserable and they'd say oh my gosh
i had no idea i was so oppressed but now
these lunatic feminists have convinced
me that i am so i'm going to burn my
bras and stop doing the dishes and
divorce my husband and
so i'm not really exaggerating these
things happened
ironically
the people laboring under a false
consciousness who are not aware of their
own
mistakes and aware of their own uh
deceit and aware of of uh the
discrepancy between their views and
reality the people who are actually
laboring under a false consciousness
are people like jesse smallett
and
crucially the people who believed jesse
smilet
they're the ones under a false god if
you think
that white supremacists wearing maga
hats carrying nooses
who recognize some minor actor from some
tv show that i've never seen
are going to yell out and try to lynch
him in the middle of the night
you
you are divorced from reality
you are laboring under a false
consciousness you need to have your
consciousness raised
by the conservatives
to
to remind you a little bit of what
reality is like
the most ridiculous reaction from the
jessie smallett incident
came from the actress ellen page now
she's pretending to be a boy named
elliot page but back during the time of
the jessie smellet thing she
acknowledged that she's a woman named
ellen page and she went on stephen
colbert's late night show and she blamed
i'm not joking she blamed the jesse
smellet attack which is which was
totally real
on
vice president mike pence
sorry i'm like
i'm like really fired up tonight this is
how this is how you have to be fired it
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now with the president and the
vice president mike pence who like
wishes i couldn't be married let's just
be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
gaycation did this in terms of
connecting the dots in terms of what
happened the other day did you see i
don't know him personally i saw i send
all of my love
connect the dots
this is what happens
if you are in a position of power and
you hate people
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career trying to cause suffering
what do you think is gonna happen what
do you think is gonna happen
what do you think was what i think
happened is that white supremacists on
the south side of chicago tried to lynch
jesse smollette i connected the dots
except
from dot to dot to dot to dot
in ellen page's mind
the dots were based on lies
that's the problem she did connect the
dots she connected the dots
of her false premises
starting with the idea that america's
this angry evil terrible place where
straight white men are just trying to
kill everybody
and going all the way back to the dot
that men and women are exactly the same
she connected all of those dots and she
ended up at the place where jesse
smallett got attacked by white
supremacists in chicago
if you start wrong
you're going to end up in a very very
very wrong place connect
the dots
i think we need to connect the dots
nothing that ellen page said is true
about mike pence or about jesus millet
or about anyone else
mike i don't want to speak for mike
pence i don't know mike pence i'm not
his spokesman but i suspect what mike
pence would say about the accusation
that she doesn't
he doesn't want her to get married to
her
lady or whatever is that
he
has no opinion about her getting married
to her lady
other than it is not possible for her to
get married to her lady no matter what
the supreme court said no matter what
anthony kennedy said it's not possible
because marriage involves sexual
difference it does and it's not like you
hate gay guys or women or it's just
because it's just what we're talking
about earlier because men and women are
different it's not possible and i'm i'm
sorry ellen page that i can't change
reality for you to make that possible
and i'm sorry that not even anthony
kennedy on the supreme court can change
reality to make that possible for you
and no one's saying that you can't have
affection for this lady or vice versa
and no one's even saying that you can't
do whatever you got i don't know
whatever you guys do but you know i no
one is even saying that
we're just saying that the reality of
marriage and marriage is again just
we're just talking about one institution
one natural institution but there are
many others the reality of these things
cannot be made to bend to your
misunderstanding and your will and your
desires it it just
can't happen
okay
and so if
if you went all the way back and you
said you know actually
men and women actually are different
and mike pence doesn't it's not he hates
me
and it's not that this is an evil
tyrannical place because the people who
want to acknowledge reality
are
you know they just they're filled with
bile and malevolence and it's just that
you know there is this thing as reality
and it's a fallen broken world and we've
all got to deal with that
if you connected all those dots then you
would look at the incident that happened
with jesse smollett his fake attack and
you would just laugh about it like dave
chappelle did
like remember dave chappelle called it
at the time he was like this isn't real
this is not
uh i don't think so do you remem okay
do you remember that dave chappelle had
this special come out around the time
and he referred to this french actor
jesse sommelier take a listen
don't ever forget what happened to that
french actor
you know what i'm talking about
juicy smoothies very french
very famous french actor
y'all never heard of jesus
so i have an unpopular admission to make
which is i never got why this line is
all that funny i thought the bit was
funny i thought that dave chappelle
talking about
how jesse obviously that this wasn't
real in chicago come on it's chicago
guys give me a break
i thought that whole thing was funny but
pronouncing his name in a french accent
i've never understood why that is funny
i know that's an unpopular take everyone
gets a big kick out of it at first i
thought the reason he was doing it was
to distance himself from jesse smallette
in that like i dave chappelle i'm a
black man and jesse smallette is a black
man but i'm embarrassed by what this
black man has done so i want to separate
us as much as possible so i'm going to
call him a frenchman but then he refers
to him as a black guy so anyway that bit
that's just a little bit of a digression
here but the point that dave made
was absolutely right
because dave chappelle
more than many people in our culture
has at least some grasp on reality
and so he knew ah i don't think so i
don't think
that that's really
going to happen it's not hateful
it's not mean it's not cruel it's not
mike pence walking around with
electrodes trying to just zap anybody
that he doesn't like it's not cruel to
say look there are realities here
and we just have to deal with that and
in a broken world that's going to be
difficult for us sometimes and there's
going to be suffering and that's just
the way the world works is that there's
suffering and we need to take that
suffering and have it be sanctifying and
edifying for us
or we can have some dude beat all the
chicks into women's swim meets
and
and much much worse than that or we can
have some dude walk into a women's
bathroom in laden county and brutalize
some girl
or
or it can get
worse and worse and worse and worse
all in the name of misguided compassion
and a misunderstanding of the world
speaking of famous women
kim kardashian
might be a lawyer
kim kardashian might become a lawyer
sort of a minor story but i did want to
touch on it
kim kardashian tweeted out omf gggg i
passed the baby bar exam looking in the
mirror i'm really proud of the woman
looking back today in the reflection for
anyone who doesn't know my law school
journey this wasn't easy or handed to me
so the baby bar is for non-traditional
students it's a first year law exam
she's failed it a bunch of times so it
does raise this question of who's going
to hire this woman as a lawyer i don't
know who would hire kim kardashian as a
lawyer anyway i'm not i'm not quite sure
but good honor congratulations that's
great she passed the board good stuff
uh the thing the thing about this story
though that
she should be careful of and we should
all be careful of is this hole i looked
in the mirror and i love that person i
see i love i love looking in the mirror
oh yeah i love you baby i love you me
i love me i'm proud i'm great i'm
awesome and i've seen other people even
non-famous people posting this sort of
stuff on on the internet
it's not
[Music]
it's the prince harry problem a man
wrapped up in himself
makes a very small package
indeed before we go big news out of uc
berkeley
the diversity equity and inclusion cult
has changed its its initialism
you know the the libs love initialisms
anachronism and uh acronyms rather
and
so they
always add the lgb goes to lgbt then
lgbtq then lgbtq
lmnop whatever and so dei is now
d-e-i-b-j
it's diversity equity inclusion
belonging
and
justice
justice
uh justice is
good i like justice it's one of the
cardinal virtues it's a moral quality or
habit which reflects the will and
inclines it to render to each into all
what belongs to them in layman's terms
it means just giving to people what they
deserve
if you're going gonna have d-e-i-b-j we
need a theory of justice we need to be
able to talk about what justice is not
just about what we want not just about
what is socially constructed but actual
justice what is it that people deserve
what is this connection to reality i
love that they added that jay i can't
wait to talk about justice because the
libs version of justice right now seems
to be the opposite of justice so let's
talk about it what is it is justice
letting the dude beat all the chicks on
the swim team is justice upending our
political order because of a virus
that's infected 43 people so far in the
last few weeks is justice giving what it
tell me baby let's talk about justice
we'll talk about it tomorrow i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see them
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show the stats
are in and they show that covet 19
targeted the elderly but lockdowns
targeted everyone that's not stopping
the democrats from pushing more
lockdowns that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen